[Musique]
bienvenue à sans filtre le podcast on
parle de ce qu'on veut que nos invités
date seach ph quand tu es avec moi deux
plans cette semaine aux podcasts ont
aussi catherine dorion qui débutait la
semaine nationale qui est venu parler
politique évidemment qui est venu parler
de secours son idéal qu'est ce qui avait
créé un politique qu est ce qu avait
communiqué comment on veut le faire puis
commença sa vie d'artiste sa réalité
d'artistes influences comme ans qui a
fait de la politique on est revenu sur
les questions du décorum aussi de qui
fait polémique dans la semaine avec son
habillement son tee shirts à tous on est
revenue un peu là dessus en autriche
après laffaire sa relation avec les
radios de québec où si ces fameuses
radio alors c'est pas beau podcast on
est pas content d'avoir reçu pour le
sport vous allez messieurs si vous aimez
le sans filtre podcast on veut vous
rappeler que notre page pétri hang est
opérationnel sur pétrone vous pouvez
nous encourage et puis en plus de nous
encourager
vous allez avoir accès à deux podcasts
exclusive par mois vous allez avoir
accès à des clones et qu'on fait depuis
mois pour répondre à vos questions vous
allez même pouvoir poser vos questions
aux invités
donc ça vous intéresse d'avoir accès à
tout ce qu'on excuse et flat le lien du
pq en aidant les descriptions dans la
déception de cette vidéo si alors
nouveau ici à bénévolat chaindon soit
des podcasts tous les mardis
l'exotisme pas différent en touche après
la fin des discussions longues on
s'amuse puis on réfléchit alors suivi
nous peut laisser des commentaires aussi
sur les discussions qu'on a réagi si
notre réponse tout le monde on se crée
entre les communautés pour pouvoir
échanger comme ce fait que ben merci
d'être là puis bon podcast bonne écoute
[Musique]
catherine dorion bienvenue chez nous
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté de venir
bon moi c'est mon micro fait un grand
chemin que c'est bon parfait j'ai appris
samedi passé parce que j'avais apporté
de famille du côté de ma mère un
partenaire l on fête noël de bonheur
puis j'ai appris que parler de politique
c'est difficile avec des gens qui sont
pas de ma génération
parce que je parlais justement du fait
qu'on voulait avoir sur le podcast puis
à la copine de mon grand-père scandale
je pense que le mal saisi mon opinion
politique puis on a commencé à parler
puis le ton enlevé je comprends qu'on
diffère que je change de sujet tout de
suite ça je crois que la politique pour
le temps des fêtes le ceux qui nous
écoutent fait attention mais ça doit
d'ici le temps que
l'idée c'est de rassembler puis de
polariser petit peu parce que tu es tu
penses que tu es quand même quelqu'un
qui prend la communication rassemblement
mais quand même je colorise polarisation
carrément mais en fait je suis en train
de développer ma pensée là dessus en
réalisant surtout parce que moi ce que
je veux c'est qu'on arrête de se taper
dessus parce que un porte-voix al parce
que c'est des jeunes travaillent maudit
parce que c'est parce que c'était ou
vieux comptes banlieue c'est tout ces
gens sont sortis dans le pied quand on
se regarde les uns les autres domaines
parce que ceux qui décident de où on
sent vogin ces deux mondes bien au
dessus nous autres qui pousse super fort
pour la croissance et donc par extension
pour détruire l'économie pour qu'on soit
pris dans une pression de performance
qui nous rend malheureuse pas constant
dans le pied quand on sai comme ceux
c'est vrai que je me suis dit jean chri
feuges gens je vais générer des
engueulades gentil ce jeu fabi n'ont
vraiment pas sauf que ce que je commence
je vois si c'est curieux comme genre
prenons grossièrement la gauche et la
droite la messe [ __ ] seuls mais ils
pouvaient aller grossièrement mettons
tout comme la droite qui sait des
complexités qui dans les dernières
décennies dernières années comme fait
genre t'es en revue toutes les
chroniques à ressortir et puis tout le
monde qui sortent picchi déjà défaut
pour travailler plus puis faut que je
voyais odorantes et s'il faut plus
d'argent vous serrent la ceinture pour
payer moins de taxes pour plus
d'autoroutes ces nouveaux ce phénomène
de ce discours le bain offre non moi je
le vois depuis que je suis depuis je
suis éveillé à la politique je vois un
discours qui me déplaît piquer comme se
faire de plus en plus décomplexée et
puis non qu'ils sont fiers d'être de
match mais on a senti que je me suis dit
genre
d'autres c'est quoi notre attitude nous
qui voulons gens juste une vie plus
simple plus de temps entre new gent
avoir le temps chill et de pratiquer
notre culture d'aller dans le bois faire
attention à ce qu'on fait à ce qu'on
mange ses meetings tout ça c'est quoi
cette attitude en général note attitude
cette vieille rien qui sera fait passer
il s'agit là politique piste de la
marque puis toute façon ce sont des
crosseurs pin un non moins l'humanité
c'est de la merde sic c'est un peu ça
maintenant d'un côté décomplexé foule
craquer le côté de demandes sont sains
et fois réalisé que rien possible pack
wii c'est peut-être polarisant parce que
ce que je fais c'est d'essayer de donner
du jus estonien le genre qui dit qu'ils
essayent d'inventer une nouvelle ère du
monde que juste produire puis c'est sûr
que si aux autres sortent de leur
léthargie de leur cynisme et a dit qu'il
s'est passé bien on va se lever pour mal
faire
oui il va y avoir des flammèches mais en
même temps si je vois pas part ou
d'autre part c'est est ce que c'est un
peu ça enfants qui s'est passé lors des
dernières élections que cette masse
dormantes le sait réveiller les
pressions couilles au centre-ville de
québec j'ai vraiment senti sous spi ce
qui est je trouve extraordinaire c'est
que justement abandonné l'oeil et au
début c'était beaucoup des jeunes qui
arrivent et qui était comment on y croit
on est tellement le choix c'est
tellement beau de voir du monde jean de
19 ans qui était comme qui vont prendre
la place bientôt le tice bientôt ils
vont être le genre d'actifs chez comme
on se repose seul lille s'en viennent
ils s'en viennent selon l'ops oms craint
qu'ils sont intelligents qu'ils sont
beaux sont inspirants
on se dit qu'est ce qu'on fait avec les
autres c'est qu'ils sont comme un peu
mais finalement pas dans notre gang de
d'idéalistes réalisme ces jeunes le lion
des parents et les amis ont déjà plein
m'emmenait à moitié l'élection devait
arriver des vieux il disait genre il y
en a notamment touché genre on ne fêtera
semblement c'est comme un gros party ces
foules artistique non mais c'était très
politique mais c'est émouvant qui est
venu nous voir est venu boire après j'en
perds le fait à mon regard de même les
yeux permet aux prix étaient vraiment
proches p 10 c'est exactement ce qu'on
faisait
continuez comme ça c'est par là qu'il
faut passer ca c j'avais des gros
frisson jeter comme jérôme adam c'est ça
nous fait du bien à nous d'avoir les
vieux qui dit yes ma mère à la 60 ans
puis elle
cet éveil la levée kikla parti québécois
n'ont ils ont vécu sa vie
c'est cela le vécu cet éveil loeb ce
mouvement lopy cette ferveur lille puis
à le garder tel a toujours pas ce qui
avait coûté sa vie puis c'était la
première fois je sais pas ou qu'elle
aboutit finalement mais cette marque a
dit kim sait c'est ce qui se passe en ce
moment c'est ce qui s'est passé dans le
fond
peut-être qu'il faut que reconnecte avec
la jeunesse puis que je comprenne que ce
qui se passe là puis dans le fond c'est
ceci le parti pour lequel j'ai toujours
voté
peut-être que c'est lui qui émergent en
ce moment c'est elle partie civile quand
ce qui est important ce pas
l'institution le parti c'est le
mouvement c'est le flou sécurité à tirer
ce coup de pouce et on a beaucoup de
préjugés des foi envers les plus vieux
petit de plus en plus je reçois des
messages en bonjour je suis un vieux con
de 70 ans et je vous appuie complètement
continuer à casser la baraque
non mais ses skis mais qui va t il son
punk aussi j'en atti reste semée faut
s'adresser cette partie là en eux au
lieu de s'adresser à la partie qu'on
aime moins vite et vous n'êtes pas
correct vous nous faites chier
moi j'ai l'impression que dans cette
dans cette génération là qui était
révolutionnaire alors à leur époque qui
s'était peut-être endormi un petit peu
puis que justement dernièrement avec
avec l'arrivée de québec solidaire
certains se sont même dits par rapport à
ta main ont retrouvé une espèce de dents
vie de droite si tu crois peut-être que
le projet de société qu'on avait quand
qu'on a décidé de militer à notre époque
peut-être que la c6 audi
peut-être que ça vaut la peine que là
est envieux
je retrouve cette france là pour
supporter les jeunes lycées touchés
parce que ça me touche je pense que j'ai
les larmes aux yeux je dis ma maman m'a
eu à 40 un talent comme pas rappeler que
moi avec la dent 79e dizaine à 10 heures
c'est à parler avec de ses amis des gens
d'audel qui était comme mais pourquoi tu
as fait c'est comme ça qu'ils disent oui
mais ces pieux qui veulent c'est les
jeunes sont le sont devenus des adultes
qui veulent que ça aille vers le faut
leur faire confiance je sais qu'ils vont
à l'énergie de transformer les choses
fac faut au moins écoutés et regardés
sais quoi qui les inspirent plus vert où
il veut aller
puis moi j'ai dit à ma mère c'est vrai
ce que tu dis je trouve ça vraiment
respectueux qui coule t mais en même
temps ce qui nous pousse ses mails je
parlais à elle au dessus de ce qui me
pousse
si ce que tu m'as transmis gens ce que
la ce pour quoi je refuse de faire
certaines choses puis que je tiens à
faire certaines autres choses
c'est à cause de toi tu es fac parce que
tu te tenu à me transmettre des valeurs
des attitudes face à la vie
puis elle ça vient sûrement de son père
beach été refusée autant dispo les vieux
contre les jeunes c'est comme pour
trouver la ligne 10 que ce qui viennent
vous autres que nous on veut transmettre
et là la valeur dans ce qu'ont en commun
ces pauvres gens travailler produire
vive croissance dispo sur l'os et
d'autre chose de bien plus beau que ceux
qui viennent vraiment loin puisqu'on a
le goût de transmettre à nos enfants
avec toi tu arrives dans le milieu
politique un peu exact c'est ce que
promet en fait j'ai plusieurs questions
posent sur ce sujet là mais est-ce que
tu étais prête
à tout ce qui est arrivé ce que tu
t'attendais à ce qui est arrivé jeudi à
partir de la campagne jusqu'à l'élection
jusqu'à la réaction du public jusqu'à la
fronde pages des journaux
non non tout ça c'est comme j'ai
l'impression de rentrer dans un jeu
vidéo gens qui se parlent bien fait que
chaque nouvelle salle jean c'est comme
wow tu vois dessus jarry me reste
presque plus de vie jusqu'à maintenant
ça va être jamais mais c'est vraiment
bizarre c'est très étrange pcc aussi que
j'ai fait de ma campagne en disant je ne
disais pas aussi claire maximum et mon
attitude qui des fois je le disais
c'était moi j'suis pas une politicienne
je suis pas comme sauter je veux pas
faire ce je vais faire d'autres choses
avec se sécher lui qui est
c'était vraiment moi je voulais se
faisait longtemps que de leurs engagé
peu je voulais utiliser la scène
politique pour qu'on soit faire ne leur
mets pas du fait d'un sens de en chanter
un espace que tout le monde va pouvoir
regarder parce que nesting rosheim noter
toutes limitées sont virés sur la
politique plus toutes ses gonds en
maudit pas que j'avais le goût de harris
est un axe phare de quad beauté puis
mais j'ai pas pensé que le fait de dire
je suis pas comme les autres je suis pas
parmi eux je suis pas une des leurs
ailes et les insultes et ne m'apparaît
pas pensé mais j'ai pas pensé faire en
arrivant le j'ai eu la réaction de
l'establishment politico médiatique qui
sont une espèce de danse à deux le tai
chi et j'étais vraiment étonné j'ai
comme un don du sang comme il n'accepte
pas et ils prennent pas vraiment que je
sois comme disait le web j'ai mieux
oui l'été avec le monde qui me regardent
que je sais qu'ils me regardent qui
marsan ne serait ce qu'ils connaissent à
bille ou comme un pâle qu'avec vous ôte
avec les autres non je suppose et lécher
le cul de la classe au pouvoir puis de
ceux qui mènent jusqu'aux et démontrer
que je veux faire partie leur gagne
sinon je post pose est dedans c'est à
cet endroit que j'ai pas vraiment le
droit d'aller exercer un poste avec
autant d'exposants de pouvoir entre
qu'on n'a pas de temps que c'est dans le
fond vu qu'on est pas pouvoir comme
partie mais quand même je pas supposé
être le si je désire pas faire partie de
la classe dominante
mais dans toute ma pensée c'est
justement somme je peux genre à mener
quelqu'un une artiste qui gagnait pacha
au pouvoir je veux que le pouvoir
descendre en beauté cette ce que ce
mouvement là que je veux faire descendre
le pouvoir vers le bas ceux qui aiment
le pouvoir sont pas d'accord excès c'est
surtout parce que c'est classe politique
le l'establishment les messieurs en
complet-cravate le ti l'image qu'on ne
serait ce que est ce que c'est vraiment
si pire que ça dans le sang ce qui est
ce que c'est vraiment des gens qui sont
là pour le pouvoir pour l'argent pousse
aussi des gens qui veulent faire avancer
le québec à leur façon je pensais les
deux en fait l'impression si tout le
monde est complexe et on est des êtres
humains puis moi je pars de l'idée que
les humains sont tus comme empathique le
jem les jeanjean fact et tu vois un
député caquistes t je le regarde avec
jouons on voit bien que les gens sont le
ab c'est bon pour ma carrière pour le
torse comme moi je vais vraiment changer
les choses petit tout se mélange et mais
sauf qu'il ya des systèmes et des
structures y a des
je pense que le système qui est le fait
que ben du monde peuvent se ramasser le
sens vraiment se demander
intelligemment puissante avec
sensibilité genre qu'est ce qu'on
souhaite pour l'avenir de notre pays
jean cescom juste la question et comme
c'est comme si j'avais l'art comme de
dire certainement la question ait pu le
thé ce que je souhaite maintenant dans
mon pays j'ai là de jean cocteau métier
dans le fond gris c'est la base cela
parce qu'on s'entend qui est souvent la
vision et à court terme c'est la
prochaine élection prochain madden 10 6
c'est le problème de la beauté de la
micra site d'avoir un système qui à
chaque avec jacques atlan en charge
parce que
ça fait qu'on est forcé de penser à
court terme mais pythie même c'est une
vision à long terme ça peut faire des
belles choses kg qui va arriver après
c'est pour ça que ça peut pas se passer
je sois parlement ces mots je pense
vraiment que si on veut changer la
politique c'est une poche pas je
changeais à pratiquer si on veut
orienter la gagne de monde qu'on est au
québec puis notre territoire à quelque
chose de plus beau et de plus un ça peut
pas se passer jusqu'au parlement qui je
sa tva nouvelles jean c'est impossible
c'est pour qui ce passe de coiffes faut
que le monde sur le terrain phase la
politique aussi puis ça ça va faire
partie de mon discours je veux dire
amener les infirmières cette écurie gens
d'être forcés de travailler des heures
de travail obligatoire a déclaré d'avoir
des conditions de travail de mardi où
vous sentez coupable parce que vous avez
gens tellement de patience ça doit être
horrible pense à ce genre tu laisses
demandant leur marque parce que pourtant
face c'était une réaction n'était pas
capable du fait passer puis le site du
monde qui souffre le résultat ce projet
jean rouch pas performant ce genre puis
tout est sur le bord du burn out by thé
ammaniti vous pouvez jolies photos
gouvernement c'est assez peut même faire
une manif ou pouvant une pétition mais
là l'étape qui vient c'est que vous vous
déjà signé même si vous êtes gênés vous
savez plus comment interagir entre vous
puis vous vous la fait qu'elle a moins
gêné de la gagne c'est ta job france
assure toi de dire aux autres sur ton
unité gens aient un sens et une réunion
pour essayer de faire de quoi genre je
sais pas comment je sais pas comment
s'organise je sais pas quoi faire mais
on essaye sud en parlant des études
trouver on sait tous d'être créatif puis
ils peuvent pilote celui là dans un gang
qui se créa presse celle qui parle le
mieux ça et elle la porte parole c'est
sa responsabilité
savait-elle que le set gagnant va
peut-être faire de couacs qui vont
inspirer nos qui m'ont inspiré d'autres
puisque c'est toute cette culture le
qu'il faut retrouver de lutte qu'on a on
l'a on possède sur ça nous a été
transmis il
mais c'est un peu normal on se pense
poche là dedans on pense qu'on sait pas
comment faire qu'il faut des structures
des syndicats des affaires les saas fee
les humains de tous temps se sont
organisés comme ceux selon leurs besoins
petit jean
c'est juste une question de pratique
pour trouver cela sinon par les
infirmières si un événement qui a prouvé
le pouvoir d'une seule personne peut
avoir c'est l'infirmière qui fait un
poste encore aimant alarme qui arrivait
justement d'heures supplémentaires
obligatoires qui était juste l'idée et
puis capable kiki qui interpellait le
ministre bouaré protégera pas dans le
sens qui se passe
personne n'a eu plus d'impact que
quelques des mouvements et incomplet a
fait plus de mal à l'image de guy
tombeau qui nous vendent et s'inscrit
ainsi que ouais c'est le pouvoir dans
l'ain dans l'individu je pense que c'est
bel et réseaux sociaux c'est
démocratique c'est exact ça donne ça
donne la chance à tout le monde d'avoir
cette parole depuis quand ces individus
pis si la communauté qui partage ses
come on voit ce tapage mais lesquin clip
aussi peut-être au passage d'autres
personnes que ça fait que tu peux parler
plus de monde puis du monde qui verrait
pas nécessairement sur la beauté de ski
virale c'est que le monde qui verrait
pas sûr voiture comme tonton discours
d'entrée alors semblé se seraient jamais
passés à telle personne a réussi une
personne aurait vu l'intégrale entre que
nous te dis allez montrer des boîtes
mais personne n'est céréales puis l'oeil
a été partagé puis a été vue par
beaucoup de personnes mais ça démontre
la différence fondamentale entre qu'avec
celle d'ap les autres partis que vous
comprenez le web l' ouest sikheti que
j'ai jamais vu des voisines qui n'existe
plus il se ramasse passe ma page mais de
dexter est justement d'affaires du
cessionnaire disco comme ceux de
dépenses à bulles etc sont autant
partager c'est tout fait l'effort juste
pour quelqu'un qui me dit c'est par
symétrie
quand tu as fait ton disque hot tub
rarement derrière la tête la pensée de
dire je parle
pauget son monde sans lui je ne pensais
qu'à la publication fait comme chez moi
je dis qu'il faut c'est que le décor
d'assemblée nationale qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est pas ça mène pas grand
chose mais le symbole est tellement fort
ce texte je l'avais fait sur une scène
dans un bar - jamais été partage ou non
plus tôt maintenant c'est comme ça à
l'assemblée nationale s'il ya quelque
chose d'artistique là dedans dans le
choix de dire de quoi
dans ce décor le qui sait pas ce positif
ça fait un choc intéressant qui se sait
je pense c'est des affaires qui sait ce
qu'ils participent entre autres avoir un
impact qui intéresse qui allume ton
cerveau qui fait que ces faits qui
peut-être donne va donner des idées à
d'autres membres de faire des trucs en
17e qui on attend pas
c'est là que je commence c'est la force
d'avoir la force insoupçonnée d'avoir
des artistes assemblée nationale c qui
écrit mme canto livre un texte se livre
avec émotion avec les hippies les livres
il si j'avais eu gentil je lui répétais
deux fois on a le feu dimanche à
schonach mi mouche si je te connais pas
beaucoup pour les textes longs comme
ceux annoncés j'aurais voulu le mais ça
va quand même un bagage d'expérience qui
fait que tout est facilement la capacité
de livrer façon vibrante un discours
puis moi j'ai une réflexion quand j'ai
vu ce puis un petit peu aussi avant avec
avec l'habillement et tous de me dire
souvent qu'un conte et l'idée des
politiciens
on est déçu parce qu'ils tiennent pas
leur premier sou il se rétracte sur
plusieurs positions
tout est arrivé en disant moi je suis
une artiste qui va qui veut prof
nécessairement devenir politicienne mais
qui va même impliqué dans la politique
de cette façon-là en restant moi même
puis comme depuis l'allemagne ils sont
comme surpris que tu fasses mais c'est
ce que tu as dit que tu allais faire des
débuts devant le monde ni de mon chalet
souvent juste pour chialer on dirait par
rapport à la politique the spare
c'est pas une espèce de désillusions
comme par les années là peut-être sauf
que le monde chiale sur l'a4 qui qui se
rétractent sur des positions le monde
change sur toi qui se rétractent toi sur
ta position mais je comprends mal
l'espèce de deux poids deux mesures dans
cette france qui est pas de logique
n'est pas une logique de est ce que
j'aime que les gens se rétracte ou pas
puis je vais chercher selon ci serait
temps que tout poste parce que je pense
que j'aurais d'ailleurs à côté du
chômage j'ai vraiment foule d'amour sur
ceux ci
c'est comme je n'aurais jamais pensé ce
pot de l'amitié en tant qu'artiste des
fois je les connaisse mon affaire pas
bon c'est quoi un peu le genre laissent
pas seul je sais j'ai vu que je suis
vulnérabilisés par les attaques
l'amour puis l'appui que je reçois jean
sa mort en direct dans le temps ça me
fait tellement du bien jean piége
souvent j'ai les larmes aux yeux dans la
vie mais moi j'ai les larmes aux yeux la
naissance comme jean samantha
d'appauvrissement de vienne me voir
jambes sont fous la folie motif puis
j'ai enregistré mes brebis
on ne sait ça me remplit ça la vraie
force céramistes artisans parce que
c'est comme mon rêve un peu qu'on soit
tous ensemble dans la même lutte puis on
arrive à faire quelque chose mais donc
il n'y a pas de logique dans le chialage
du monde je pense que j'en général et
comme une grosse poche de chialage au
dessus du québec jean qui qui qui qui
colore l'ambiance pikine où rentrent
tout un peu frustré gens chacun de nous
certains plus que d'autres se montrent
plus positif que d'autres avoir l'heure
juste 10% de l'ambiance sur la jambe
d'un autre c'est 100% je me dis ils sont
celles au parti c'est comme si chaque
fois qui est quoi qui sort de ce qu'on
attend la réaction sans même y penser ça
va être genre rien hein et puis si tu le
sais pas c'est quoi un surcoût de
fouquerolles les maisons vont te le dire
jean ils vont marteler ça n'a pas de bon
sens pas comme moi elle a pas de bon
sens
on a le goût de chialer janvier comme
cela ce je trouve ça vraiment négatif
j'ai l'impression que comme notre karma
du moment que tu vas voir c'est comment
vit gentil mouton est alcoolique tu
manges mal tu fais pas d'exercice qui
topo d'amis genre tu as ta job ça va mal
c'était le genre qui bosse des maths
elle-même pupilles et oui on dit mais tu
peux continuer au lit toute ta vie ou
qui peut décider que tu arrêtes de bord
que tu veux savoir prendre une marche
tous les jours que tu veux manger bien
que tu vas tu peux faire c'est aussi le
taux de chômage en mai abandonné le
québec jean qu'est ce qu'on fait on
passe une autre vie à cholet où on fait
comme banque le montre ce qui sera c'est
seul paysage dans lequel on est le
paysage on peut même si les québécois
sont des carcasses a pas de mention
parce que le québec s'en vont on peut
faire ce mais on peut aussi dire ça
c'est le paysage à partir duquel faut
qu'on fasse de quoi ou boum puis je vois
faire de quoi puis le moins la partie ce
moment j'ai décidé de faire de quoi la
dette dans l'action de construire petit
à petit avec le monde autour de moi des
choses des propositions de mon troll sur
moi je m'en fout vraiment plus qu'avant
je gagne je suis comme ok toi tu fais
quoi
tous constructeurs se construire n'est
pas un interlocuteur valable pour moi si
peu qu'on sache à l'otan que tu veux moi
je me tourne vers ceux qui construisent
on va partir quelque chose puisqu'il
peut rester là mais c'est pas un peu une
attitude de pré show conversys telle
vite à la personne que tu charles qui
tempo qui traite de folle wever
est-ce que tu essaie d'aller chercher
cette personne est ce que tu as aidé la
convertible intuitif low cost
l'abandonnent je commence par ceux qui
construisent quelque chose moi il y en a
en masse du monde conçu quelque chose à
convertir et monde s'en fout l'acte
effectivement dix ans des belles
personnes qui font des trucs qui
touchent comme sérieuses et lyon nous
pas nécessairement prends ta carte de q
est-ce le genre je sais pas mais tu es
un militant
tu te souviens de baptiste humaine tout
voyons de boulangerie me tondant tâche
rue en est souvent une bleue une
boulangerie pillée des sticks toutes ces
employés ça serait déjà en réinsertion
ça marche monter cette personne est une
mixture billy talent c'est des militants
le savent pas nécessairement m'étais je
dit est en train de travailler pour le
bien commun
puis c'est à des gens comme toi que
doivent aller les ressources de l'état
pas des milliards des pétrolières du
monde qui scrap bien commencé c'est
comme amendé on prend conscience que
notre lutte c'est la même chose puis tu
ai fait moi je commence par ce monde là
puis si tout le monde qui construisent
finissent par se réunir les gens qui ont
jugé au lit qu'est-ce qu'ils vont être
capables de nous opposer
on veut qu'on sonne force aux autres
depuis des années de pratique à chaud
les gens ils sont pas pratiqués à bâtir
une force fac ils vont finir par dire
d'un coude ans est devenue forte c'est
devenu beau joe embarqué ou bien ils
vont rester vont chercher ils seront pas
menaçante et peut-être l'impression que
pour qu'un parti se fasse élire quelques
soldats un mouvement incroyable mais
somme toute une vie pour ça mais vous
atlantis qui se passe bon ça mais dix
députés
c'est la croissance est incroyable mais
ça reste qu est ce que pour se faire
élire n'a pas le choix de faire des
compromis d'avc de chercher tout le
monde de sortir un petit peu vous faut
jamais faire le con premier des
compromis ça dépasse si c'est des choses
qu'on apprend pitt qui nous change
intelligemment pour parce que tout le
monde est en relation avec le monde mais
compromis de gens je laisse de côté mes
vraies idées pour peut-être aller
chercher plus de monde que je trouve que
c'est vraiment un bon chemin et est
cessible
c'est pas vrai que les québécois ont des
idées qui changeront pop que le faut que
tu ailles chercher des électeurs
je pense qu'il s'est passé la dernière
l'action ce pas nécessairement les idées
qu'ils sont
l'idée que les parties proposées qui ont
changé et si québec solidaire et existe
depuis des années sauf que j'ai
l'impression que c'est la pensée commune
qui a changé ici j'ai l'impression que
ça va pas dans l'autre sens les tuer les
pressions qu une bascule qui est parti
d'un côté pic avec les principes de côté
par exemple la bascule qui est parti
d'un côté qui partent vers le côté de
quoi non mais dans le fond le la bascule
qui est qui qui recommencent à
redescendre vers justement le peut-être
la décroissance mettons largement qui -
mais surtout par les enjeux
environnementaux au petit jeu c'est
resté je pense que pense le style
mettons dans que de cette élection si ou
est ce que c'est la cac et québec
solidaire qui sont sortis l'état turc a
même procédé parties opposées mais moi
je pense que la bascule est parti vers
le changement
ça c'est que la vie ça retourne pas
l'autre bord j'ai pas l'impression que
la pensée commune vont retourner
serveurs des anciens partis vers là à
moins que les anciens partis change lors
leur ligne mais j'ai pas l'impression
que ça va repartir vers les anciennes
idées c'est alain deneault qui appelait
sur l'extrême centre mou gauche droite
est ce que vous allez vous recentrez non
c'est devenu l'extrême centre c'est
l'extrême rien c'est mou ça fait plus ça
marche put je comprends même pas des
gens qui décident d'aller s'impliquer
dans un parti centre en ce moment parce
que on voit bien le sas
c'est pas nous qui nous radicalise on
met l'époque se radicalise
elle est quand on arrête pas de parler
les cordes entre les riches et les
pauvres qui se creuse du monde qui ont
besoin que de se payer des soins de
santé de base
la solitude dumontier est atroce le
pauvre est une misère énorme
un vieux mais je ne commande doit sentir
vulnérable quand on est tout croche
notre corps est recraché
on réfléchit moins clairement les choses
nous paraissent compliqués que le monde
change tellement vite qu'on n'est même
pas adapté gens à ce qui s'est passé la
dernière année péter tout seul - pas une
personne que tu peux appeler jean qu'il
va trouver ce important de les retarder
je trouve ce
c'est radical
cette situation la radio puis ce qui se
passe avec l'environnement c'est radical
ou si avec bref tout ça c'est l'époque
qui radical qui se radicalise puis les
solutions de retrait ce cas doivent être
à la hauteur de ce qui se passe de la
situation ouais c'est pas nécessairement
radical dans le sens de votre côté il
tout doit y est en feu ce procès c'est
juste genre faut que ton plein pour
l'environnement il soit bonne il soit
cruelle soit cohérent intelligent qui
haïti qui soit concret le volet dans des
paroles en l'air dire à peu près on
al'intention de peut-être un jour dit
c'est parce que j'ai l'impression de
parler de ceux justement à mon party de
noël ça mais moi je comparais un petit
peu l'est parce qu'on en avait déjà
parlé sur le sur le podcast pense de
dire les gens hésitaient à la cac et
québec solidaire alors que ça pourrait
pas être plus éloigné d'un spectre mais
le monde voter pour le changement
j'ai l'impression que aux états unis
avec donald trump sûr que beaucoup de
monde qui ont motivé notre choix n'était
pas d'accord avec donald trump
parce que y ont voté pour le changement
puisque c'est lui qui proposait le plus
grand changement par le monde il ya
beaucoup de monde qui doivent pas savoir
qui doit vouloir voter
pour n'importe quoi sauf qu'ils étaient
là dès jeudi puis du monde pas
nécessairement très informé vont voter
quand même qu'ils vont faire le choix de
dire ok moi je vois que pour n'importe
quoi de nouveau pour ce phénomène qui
nous vaut le coup il a dit qu au québec
qui eut le tnp des eaux fédérales c'est
des moments comme ça où est ce que les
nouveaux par ses piques et qu'on compte
qu'on dorme dans le train je pense que
ça traduit justement un écoeurement
pires désillusions mais en même temps
sémou chez dams a eu non plus de
démoniser des partis et on attend d'être
des partisans qu est d'être que le pq
c'était là la pire des merdes pu tester
le tir par simone berriau sont attachés
en plus seulement sont réellement tâche
à ce parti dont les pq est un parti
c'est du monde qui qui veulent faire une
différence à la manière pic qui essaie
de le faire la meilleure façon possible
avec selon leur valeur
pitié
c'est à toi je te poser la question est
ce que les complet cravate s'est demandé
yves holcim et non ses obligés jj fait
attention beaucoup d'entrevues de sept
minutes
ces genres je disais je trouve ça fou
l'important du sebin corps et puis c'est
un costume steam dont gabriel et
monsieur je pense y trouvons là dedans
d'ailleurs t il ya un certain
attachement à ce que son nom a peut-être
que sont pas ça vient d'eux mêmes qui
trouvent ça beau pourquoi on est attaché
à des choses ça nous regarde antijeu
jaillit paul complet cravate et moi à
bien antérieur je me sens comme un
personnage de film poche je me sens pas
bien je suis gêné je serais vraiment mal
de me présenter de même puis tout le
monde me voit à la télé le même là je
réponds tu vois ce que je trouve que
c'est un costume qui fait honte mais
c'est pas moi tu veux pas je sais c'est
lui pis ce gisèle pelouse la france et
moi parce que comme vous parce que la
politique c'est trop dur
certainement il ya des gens qui sont là
pour les mauvaises raisons là dedans
probablement ça existe mais c'est du
reste ici faire la politique qui je
pense que tu fais ça tu enrichi aux
pouilles thema napalm en plus facile que
la politique mais c'est une des manières
y en a qui quand et de rendu quant à
monter d'un échelon le pit était ami
avec les plus big shot du québec parce
que tu as eu du pouvoir de leur donner
des contrôles que l'appreil te quitter
je pense que moi je serais pas là dessus
puis je vois paul l'attrait mais
j'imagine qu'ils aient un accès ce qui
les fait bander gain de suite tous ces
iem c'était le pouvoir corrompt dit le
week-end faut que tu le sais la clé ce
que je peux te disent que c'est une
drôle et du joint qui commence et que ça
m'a menti
la question du décorum parce que ça a
été le sujet dans les dernières semaines
si on peut parler d'un livre utile
[Musique]
g ça date pas d'hier dit les pires a
certainement une raison d'être dans un
sens à ces petits pics en regarde à
travers tout l'elysée pas que les
sociétés jamais un roi qui était en tee
shirt qui s'habille comme les paysans ou
thé ben heck
dans des sociétés vraiment galetas oui
les expériences politiques ou legault
qui dirige n'est que moi mon rôle c'est
dj mais c'est juste ma job tout en est
un autre qui comme comme genre de
metteur en scène dans une création
collective le but ici il lève le ton
trop aussi comment cette autoroute
artois comm
mais qu'est-ce qui fait mettons que que
les juges ou que les politiciens ou que
tu sais tu klaus lui qui ont un certain
standing aucune espèce de costumes
qu'alexis que c'est pour toi qu'est ce
que tu penses que ça je pense que ça
vaut vraiment raison d'imaginer ben je
m'en fous juge comme je pense que j'ai
passé j'ai pas l'espèce de gênes qui
comprend ckoi l'importance de ce genre
la balle est donc mais je respecte ce
qu'il trouve ça important mais me
demandez pas de trouver ça important
avec vous jean je m'excuse
ça me fait rien moi je respect je te
respecte pas plus pas c'était bien a dit
je respecte pas plus parce tâter la
stèle dans l'assemblée nationale en
commençant sa phrase par madame la
présence de ce président ou lutte
adressé à la personne en face de qui qui
tu parles tu vois pas le rapport qui ça
ne m'inspire pas respect sauf que je ne
dis pas que ça m'inspire de l'irrespect
pts au dessus juste comme c'est étrange
pour moi puis pour moi ce qui m'inspire
le respect c'est ce qu'on était en fait
on est maintenant vu on fait toujours un
peu de projection c'est moi qui m'en
inspire le respect c'est quand est
fidèle à tallinn quand une cantine
député ratthé désir viennent de ton
coeur pippa de ce qu'on te dit qu'il
fallait que tu penses quand une pensée
originale qui était capable de la porter
en avant pictet dans la bonté pictet
d'antiques suspect de l'énergie aux
autres tu essaies d'en donner puis bon
moi ce que je respecte sa sortie puis
projection puis j'exigerai des autres
qui sont là en politique d'être comme
ceux qui jaillissent à caen j'ai vous à
dire des gens de deux phrases vides ne
pas utiliser l'espace qui ont pour faire
quelque chose de bien et de mieux que ce
jeu comme c'est pas acheter qui moi
comme celle de la projection je me dis
les gens qui me regardent
je veux qu'ils me respectent et pour
qu'ils me respectent faut que je sois
ses fonctions comme geneviève donc soit
respectable pour de vrai le profondément
soit toi six mois puis que je sois le
que j'ai sonné sens du temps au temps
ce que tu as dit respectable ce risque
est à l'heure exacte qui est donc mais
au fond de la projection aussi pis si
pour vous le respect c'est bien même
considère que je ne mérite pas le
respecter mais on s'entend pas mais
c'est correct qu'on s'entende pas on est
dans la maison du peuple avec des gens
élus par le monde au québec tu sais pas
que moi ils m'ont élu que j'ai fait
campagne de m qui peut accepter qu'on
s'entende pas que ce soit correct que
moi je suis moi de même c'est ce que je
propose comme style de politique tout
propose un autre style de politique ni
de respectabilité bon ben allons-y
proposons les deux faisons chacun
démonstration déployons nous pour voir
ce qui va faire le plus de petits moi
j'ai l'institution que ce que je fais
pour faire bien plus de petits qu'est ce
que font qui ont rendu la politique
plate piqué personnes suis sauté
c'est ce que je pense c'est mon bet et
le g520 dans tous les cas c'est certain
que cette attitude là qui te fait par
les plus grands enfants en politique et
au fait que beaucoup de monde qui ont vu
la politique différemment sûrement du
monde qui devait se sentir déconnecté
des jeunes principalement il va se
sentir déconnecter un peu puis qui sont
retrouvés à travers toi ce cirque sights
ait eu cet effet l'heure c'est certain
mais pourrait revenir à ce qu étudier
d'homme je sais pas
ça date de loin le tir le décor en aide
à des dirigeants système féodaux féodal
en d2 système féodal
c'était pour imposer cela imposer le
respect pour prouver que lui avait le
roi avait de l'argent et les paysans
n'ont fait que peu se payer des habits
extravagant et tout mais maintenant
c'est plus encore mettons comprend
maintenant la religion catholique je
pense que ça aurait collé si l épaule
décorum qui vient ottoman sûrement pas
si chaud mais ça personne on peut
développer des nouveaux types de décors
en milieu humide et quand même de
l'église celui des féodaux pillay à
celui des habits noirs mais
mais messi enfin si on bat c'est quand
tu dis je pense que ça a récolé
d'enfants qui sionisme est un mouvement
ça a collé moi je veux qu'on fasse un
mouvement spontané quelque chose de cool
au québec quelque chose aussi cool que
la révolution tranquille peut-être même
qui va plus loin tic dans dans
l'émancipation que dans tout ça c'est
que si on arrive à faire ce sigean la
mayonnaise punk ça colle on va avoir des
nouveaux codes puis on va s'attacher à
ces nouveaux codes dont ça se peut que
ces nouveaux codes là ça soit et ils ont
peu de têtes chacun soit même genre ça
serait cool codes du genre si vous avez
le goûter vous êtes inspiré par
quelqu'un vous habiller par exemple
bigot metal woods est autrement tout le
goût toiles inspirées autrement gaujean
pis c'est ça rejoint toutes sortes de
problèmes de société qu'on a en ce
moment et quand je dis est en tout cas
on considère les uns les autres c'est on
va on veut stigmatiser la femme voilée
la chanteuse lesbiennes qui veut pas ça
bien petite madame on veut stigmatiser
on va stigmatiser l'innocent en banlieue
qui dit des affaires sans réfléchir on
vote on va tout va que là on est en
train de séparer le monde anti-gang en
disant c'est correct c'est pas correct
on peut toujours enlever le jugement
c'est correct c'est pas correct juste
rentré en contact que ça pourrais tu
devenais genre une de nos principales
bases sur lesquelles on essaye de faire
de quoi
peu importe si tu as le droit d' ok
tiges par là je sais pas moi je parle à
quelqu'un
ma voisine raciste le avant des gens
comme puissance en même temps je vois tu
pas changé disait juste comme avant
toute chose commencé par développer en
respect malgré nous des moissons et en
qui on trouve qu'ils ont peu dans le
hockey mais c'est elle qui est ma
voisine c'est avec elle que je vip c'est
la même chose reste du territoire au
québec on vit avec le monde son lot le
hac on peut tu comme script quoi entre
nous le on est rendu là le t on en est
plutôt cruel de terrain commun sur
lequel on peut faire d'autres choses que
je serai jugé puis sa semaine dans des
cases exc moi ça colle pas compte mais
on est due pour réinventer de quoi me
semble trop non
parlant de
des voisins de raciste ma voisine me
parle plus depuis calais non vraiment
aller coûte beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup à
tout prix des billets coûtent été
annoncé que ben je sais pas si mes m et
non non c'est juste que depuis les
dernières semaines
je m'habille mal ça pas de concert avec
l'oeil comme on parle popu médecins
comme mais ça m'amène à une question que
je voulais poser
nous on vient de québec et les radios de
québec on écouter les radios québec puis
ça doit tellement est difficile dans ta
position à québec mais totalise souvent
pittem qui thème de la baule mais moi je
les aime aussi mais ça je sais pas
combien ça va durer je sais que c'est
pas une relation de confiance profonde
parce qu'il ya eu 13 ans qui fit parlent
qu'ils ont à présent tu pars li n dré
personnes ont brandi le tarif paulo avec
ton dico la cassette puis la langue de
bois le tfc puis sont même si tu as et
services que je souhaite à tous même si
des affiches trouvions pas dans leurs
justes l'attitude que j'ai de dire des
tangos je veux rentrer en contact pour
vous c'est des humains ne sont pas juste
des machines à idéologie chansons comme
sont contents que j'aille cette attitude
là avec eux qui salit ouvre en échange
eux aussi appelés quelque chose je ne
ferai pas changé d'idée je le sais mais
déjà le fait qu'ils me laissent ils me
laissent blablater l'outil genre il est
vraiment prendre des motos de la gombe
c'est un spectacle même à moi en fait
parce que je tenais à québec qu'il y
avait une annonce était pour le show
jeff fillion ce poste-là son show non un
show le spectacle
non non mais chic chic chic su
patiemment dans l'émission radio de
l'hadopi avait comme c'était un peu pour
son émission qui passait sur une arête
aptc comme tunein à 12h30 pour défiler
en mots c'est quoi son heure de
diffusion mais il a peu pour son show
c'était c'était lui qui a des trucs
horribles par rapport à québec solidaire
par rapport à toi c'était la pub de son
show le dis à tous les genres ai dit que
je crie ça rien de mes journées toujours
à tiroirs collègues cependant il faut
que je joue vraiment
ça me rend malade si je fais pas quelque
chose et lui genre ils l'ont accusé rien
fourier puis c'est viscéral en plus puis
moi j'ai écouté sur les faty sacrément
comment dans cette ville-là avec les
mollahs mais si tu me dis que c'est pas
tout ça tant mieux
sauf que je sais pour un fake lui
beaucoup de cas d'écouté des choses même
s'il a beaucoup de que des copies je
veux dire ce qu'ils disaient depuis jeff
fillion se dissipe apprend fois qu'il
fait ça mais ce qu'ils actuelle une
seule personne ne s'était pas d'accord
politique maïs non non il fait il y
avait des fixations comme ce sont
d'autres personnes c'est je pense une
forme de sous genres y est tellement
je trouve tellement peau stables ce que
le linge ou totalement
juste le fait d'en parler maintenant ja
je me dis ils vont gagner seul puisque
sa valeur start et non mais j'ose même
pas non mais suffisent qui est tellement
ça se pourrait très bien puisque genre
et ça déclenche le petit que le genre
est comme dit jean py que je devienne
son obsession il le fait avec lotfi le
fait avec sophie chiasson fait avec pied
c'est eu lieu quelque chose de faux qui
dans cette attitude là puisque le
problème mais moi je le vois juste comme
ça et je l'aï même pas je suis juste ça
y est ça partirait de loin pour remettre
ce gala si bon chemin et sauf que sauf
que je sais pas quoi faire avec ceux là
où il ya du monde mais ce qui me fait
peur c'est que je suis c'est d'être je
suis pas en contact avec ses auditeurs
qui habite maintenant centre-ville de
québec c'est bien correct je m'en fous
un peu
mais est-ce que genre j'en prendrai mes
enfants au lieu de grimper capreau gens
qui vont pas c'est qu'ils vont faire de
quoi mais le problème avec lui c'est
radio l'os c'est cueillir rien quitte
voisine qui va le faire changer d'idée
non taillés pas si comme je te dis ici
se dit il rien pitié on n'est plus dans
la rue dans les faits en hippie dans
l'objectivité on est complètement dans
l'idéologie puis c'était absolument rien
de brillant qui pourrait amener une
liste de faits sur mettons pour le temps
qu'on parle du troisième ligne pourquoi
tu sais pas une bonne dépit même si très
les meilleurs arguments du monde et rien
que d'être lui aussi du monde qui parle
qui parle qui parle mais c'est basé sur
rien de solide le t on s'appuie sur ce
pas sur l'effet sur la vérité seppi
s'est dit content à la du post vérité le
territoire
c'est le même problème justement ces 6 6
1 6 2 monde mais on a parlé à se passer
avec les pharmaciens aussi monde qui ont
des feelings sur des choses qui ont des
opinions puis sa part le tout pendant
cinq minutes
en fait toute la journée métiers avec
différents invités sous de faire un
sujet pis
c'est les gens qui font ça pour du cash
et des fesses le montat pas trop trimé
mais non seulement aux états unis une
faute et c'est comme genre basé sur
comme si ça allait parler de l'actualité
mais dans le fond c'est ce que je trouve
positif c'est que ce sont là depuis
vraiment longtemps on vraiment là depuis
longtemps mon genre il ya des poches
d'eau de stars qui sont pas la société
ts quand même pas jean le téléjournal de
radio canada
quoique ces jeux pas mal juste déjà plus
dans la tranche plusieurs jeux de la
société qui coûte cher mais bref on est
rendus dans un space derrière de
déconstruction des médias où chacun ses
poches roadster puisque je trouve
positif c'est qu'en leur poche
d'auditeurs
c'est pas tes ils vont
finalement sont quand même plus angers
s'était pas déjà qu'ils sont en ce
moment au score de ski bosses de ski
déterminer l'avenir
puis un truc comme votre podcast et
plein d'autres de ce genre le vous avez
des poches du temple c'est comme
vraiment plus décès comme genre de
l'infotainment c'est quand même pas mal
plus sincères l'autre c'est comme un
livre et ses yeux ceux aussi qui se
développe
houle vite ben vi qui va avoir des
impacts sociologique vraiment drôle
autant la radio privée de québec a eu
des impacts sociologie vraiment gros
autant ça ce style d'affaires le vaut
prendre la place pie si vous êtes en
train de changer le paysage de la pensée
et le au québec si c'est quand même
piquant les agents tout le monde doit
s'impliquer
si on avait voulu faire mais j'ai on a
parlé avec nicolas ouellet parlait d
american life qui est un mode radio à
chicago pin qui est consommé si un des
podcasts les plus écoutées au monde qui
n'est vraiment plus de personnes qui
tout le podcast qui demande qui écoute
le show de radio alors tel qui est ce
une bonne nouvelle parce que moi mettons
dame
dans le problème le problème avec ton
éric duhaime - jeff fillion c'est pas
moi j'ai pas de problème avec ces gens
là
le problème que j'ai c'est avec les gens
qui leur donne un micro moi c'est ça que
moi je comprends pas parce que mettons
éric duhaime la journée de une journée
de l'homme
il a fait un post sur facebook où est ce
qu'ils disaient que en gros il disait
qu'il voulait atteindre l'égalité mais
dans l'autre sens
il voulait que les hommes de règle de
vie des hommes c'est qu'on arrête de
parler juste des femmes que par les
hommes mais moi je me rappelle avoir lu
ce qu'y avoir eu le sentiment qu'ils
étaient complètement déconnecté puis
cela je donne mon opinion puis on est à
100 field plusieurs mon opinion je m'en
fous que le monde qui écoutent ce ils
sachent qu'ils entendent qu'est ce que
moi je pense mais l'opinion l'impression
que j'ai vu ce qui était complètement
déconnecté puis je m'étais dit c'est pas
lui
j'ai pas de problème avec lui mais
pourquoi pour des chiffes pour des cotes
d'écouté
pourquoi quelqu'un lui donne un un micro
en 2018 encore dit puis sur ta seule me
suis dit la meilleure chose qui peut
arriver c'est quand on essaie que des
coutelas ne viennent plus assez élevé
pour justifier de données jam à
quelqu'un qui a des propos d'un tiers
des propos haineux ou misogyne en face
comme jeff fillion le qui s'est faite
main d'or plusieurs fois des oiseaux
radio pillot bâtissons radios pirates
sur internet fait que
ce que j'aurais voulu ne pas lui donner
mais ils s'accordent avec lui mais sauf
qu est ce que je sais c'est d'amener
tout va migrer vers les femmes le google
facebook toutes les médias vont
commettre t'oublie gémir et là dedans
pilot est ce qu'on veut dire encore
briand google maintenant au moins si tu
choisis d'aller écouter des personnes
c'est maintenant que c'est maintenant
que je me regarde dans le miroir pendant
15 minutes que je me répète que je suis
là depuis la tulette je suis la tulette
après 15 minutes ça se peut que je
commence à y croire
oui je pense que ça c'est un des
problèmes si tout le monde et tout le
monde et est indépendant puis choisit le
podcast et écoute dans ton chant ben ça
se peut que le gars mettons qui rentrent
de sa job ça se peut qu'ils écoutent un
podcast de sport qui passe par les du
canadien mais le sitac 98 ici d'un choix
québec pour entendre parler du canadien
et entend parler pendant 45 minutes de
comment catherine dorion ainsi à porte
un tee shirt il me pourrait le mettre à
radio canada elle aussi seppi
en fait c'est rendu la radio numéro un
au québec la touques and meet you do you
do d'options tique quand même encore un
public pour ce prime
moi j'ai une hypothèse que je suis
convaincu que sega ne pense vraiment pas
tout ce qu'ils veulent alors
profondément moi je pense que la radio
ce interchangeables vraiment facilement
si c'était pas des cotes d'écouté car là
c'est moi je pense qu'il donne un show
procédera le mec mais en cas d'école à
cépie et tous les moyens sont bons le
sait on veut de ses piles c'est à main
très sympa les gens c'est comme ça peut
même et au traditionnel ils sont menacés
en ce moment justement parce que tout
migrant vers les grosses les
accompagnent la silicon valley c'est je
vois comment je peux donner un entrevue
que avec le journaliste on voit quand
même loin où c'est quand même
intéressant puis le titre est tellement
d'éguzon seulement du groupe byd
grossier j'emmène dans des mails et fois
dans le devoir gens excités comme
c'est rendu triste c'est comme si genre
une course vers en fait beaucoup de
sociologues parlent de jusqu'où le
capitalisme nous emmener en ce moment
c'est rendu que genre comme un cas pas
sur le temps de cerveau disponible est
devenu le produit taxi toi t'es sur
facebook où tu es instagram ton cerveau
je peux le vendre à des annonceurs puis
je te fais passer des pubs c'est moi qui
fais de l'argent c'est toi qui reçoit le
désagrément de la publicité mais en
échange des comptes atteint un stade g
nous que genre moi je vends ton temps de
cerveau disponible
puis ça c'est devenu la manne fac genre
toutes sont toutes en train de
s'orienter va avoir notre attention
maintenant tout un système capitaliste
d'information entertainment puis de
vente de publicités super élaborés l'un
des psychologues gens qui travaillent là
dessus des technologues suis pas pointu
le nous autres on se promène dans la
ville jean py le notre attention
notre notre temps de cerveau disponible
est soumis à une machine de guerre comme
jean c'est un des écrans partout de ton
téléphone tu as des idées dans le
journal tifa clos à mon agent on est
désorienté gens c'est crispant mauvais
pour la santé mentale
on est toutes là dedans même temps
quitté pour un couple et non trois comme
jeux picards d'être bien son chiche dans
le bourg ge
il ya tellement d'informations c'est une
guerre puis qu'est-ce qu'est ce que la
personne va penser qu est ce qu elle va
acheter pour qu'ils avaient voté tout
social c'est là que l'argent serait le
pacte et c'est complètement malsain
c'est fou le jeu trop c'est d'une
tristesse parce que même ceux qui
travaillent d'aimer dieu vont embarquer
l'adapa choix le monde depuis
depuis la tension fait si je veux gagner
ce genre t'es gros titres des grosses
grosses iltika voir apple sur youtube
mais même date là dedans oui mais aussi
chez c'est quoi on sait c'est quoi si on
a aimé mais là dedans même temps comment
faire pour appeler l'attention du monde
pour leur dire nous on utilise des en
fait des petits clips enfants des
discussions on isole des segments des
discussions pour essayer de diriger les
gens vers la patente au complet qui
s'intéressent un sujet précis ça me
tombe leur sapin vidéo 2 hors batterie
yellow pitié
on le voit la différence entre la
tension clic en clic le contenu à
l'intérieur
ignorance et puis les têtes et les
jambes et le mcc coeur de pirate qui en
parle à tout le monde en parle c'est que
le monde fait quoi
- c'est le monde dans le monde le titre
puis c'est comment ou un coeur de pirate
de la force utilise l'article ses passes
au compteur
mon premier m'a pris mon expérience de
ces caches tu es mon premier scream que
j'ai fait je n'ai juste d'assermenter
gens plus jamais un script kiddies genre
je te je mettais déjà fait de la
réflexion mais tuyaux pour le caméra il
ya des grosses lumières dans ta face des
questions en rafale ont un peu top top
agressif je t es assez drôle ça
ressemble aux méthodes d'interrogatoire
les plus soft en ex-urss y met une
grosse lumière d'en face au prévenu que
c'était des questions orales et que je
dis ça comme un peu à la légère
puis le titre était catherine dorion ce
dit se sentir comme en urss
c'est ça la tête tellement teuf
c'est ce club g comme ça sur la tête
tellement tough le mois moi je vois
c'est la cia et le gaz mais le mime sur
internet là la mineuse l'environnement
ces combines banon mais si c'est elle
qui se fait prendre il se fait à se
prendre dans nos scrupules c'est un fait
pitié se fait poser un million de
questions plus clairement je ne sais pas
de quoi tu parles puis c'est correct je
veux dire tu viens de rentrer puis
optimalement tu le seuil des petits
malades cela dominé ça mais bon
finalement je serai pas ministre et
aimer mais lotus et poti leclerc my home
ou si je le sais pas si je te colle il
faut dans l'empathie qu'il y en avait on
n'a rien quitte à crampons les
journalistes ont une bonne qualité comme
techno cour d'école
mais ça passe au dessus il faut que tu
sois blindé de soi condamnable et sur
tout les sujets mais puisque ce que je
trouve le plus tough s'est passé un
moment alors que moi je suis les
journalistes même si je disais tantôt
que j'étais pas impressionner par les
politiques je prends impressionné non
plus par les journalistes mais c'est
après quand ils sortent leur
l'information people je pense à genre
forcément mark ivanir ce je pense à au
monde qui même qui me suivent qui vont
super cobra c'est plein de gens je
pensais qu'ils étaient coup ils vont en
dessous c'est ça votre supplice c'est
comme une forme de guerre psychologique
jantes de gomme
pour que réussisse à
à développer des liens une fidélité
entre toi pita gagne que tu va grossir
qui soit plus forte que ces affaires
lourdes sont constantes contre les
tontons propres et si la meilleure façon
de contrôler récit parce que c'est ce
bateau en mouvement c'est quel récit
quelle histoire on veut écrire ensemble
c'est de le faire avec les autres parce
que quand les autres sont comme se
sentent impliqués puissante que leur
présence dans le mouvement change de
quad
ils sont issa et de l'autisme comme
genre bon ben on est attaqué plus tôt
que la fille anna va j'en suis un match
de plus et le jeune communauté
ouais c'est ça c'est la seule à faire je
vois pas comment on pourrait pour créer
des communautés noires mais son but a
tenté que automne on crée une communauté
les artistes créent une communauté déjà
communautaire qu'une communauté les
groupes qui s'organisent eux parlent
tantôt des infirmières communauté pu
changer ça semble prendre bien raconter
ta vie d'ensemble pas sucré et un but
commun puis tu t'en vas voir quelques
parts et saint-exupéry qui disait ça
crie ça crée des liens sacrés de l'amour
saint-exupéry des sémites
c'est pas se regarder l'un l'autre c'est
regarder ensemble dans la même direction
c'est bien on a fait des trucs sa levée
puis chacun avait son euro oatei avait
décelé assez vergote comme il y avait
jean l'organisatrice 100m j'en serais
morte et y avait comme tout le monde au
son talent particulier vraiment poussé
fort plus au lieu d'être moins comme
d'habitude avec toute une gamme
d'artistes font la même chose que moi
j'avais déjà complètement différents
mais ensemble jean tu es seul le sait ça
crée des liens bien plus fort que ce
qu'on avait passé un mois en chine et
dans un chalet même si on adore ce pas
ce qui te fait qu d aider des
contrecoups des avancées des types c'est
grâce aux liens que développe et que ça
marche et fac ce lien le titiller tout a
coûté ça c'est à force de ce curieux ton
parcours avant la politique
sur sa une couple de fois oui je crois
on te suit facto
photo serait mon meilleur notre
meilleure amie
club les gens huit ans est ce là dessus
ajoute la un shojo qu on fait ça débute
le 9 et 7 ans dans le cadre du festival
de jazz de québec c'est comme des
lectures de textes et des musiques
oui j'ai fait plein d'affaires nommément
des coûts fixes et kouamé ton parcours
tu commences et mettons artistique
artistiquement parlant moi j'ai fait je
vais pas conservatoire pied j'ai
commencé j'étais à québec
je t'ai actrice puis je me suis assez
vite tanné de par les textes des autres
facs avec des amis des créateurs on
s'est mis à faire nos propres shows puis
j'ai fait ce piège me soumets à cela met
à faire du nabot israël sur scène parce
que j'ai fait un peu de la même chose
mais que la musique me souviens qu'ils
délivrent puis je me suis mis à faire
des conférences dans des cgpi le tout ça
était comme de l'art engagé fait que je
me suis mis de plus en plus à parler
politique qui je me demandais tout le
temps comment que j'ai fait ça pendant
10 15 ans j'ai ça marche vraiment bien
en fait avant de faire mon avant de
décider de faire toute cette année je
fais de la politique toute l'année parce
que j'ai commencé avec une course à
l'investiture se sait pour déterminer
qui sera la candidate depuis janvier
celle là dedans fond la caisse mais
l'année d'avant je n'ai acheté que ma
soeur la bloquant pas mon nom qu'une
boîte de bourles dans le bourg au bord
d'une rivière gens le voient qu'ils
m'ont boosté
je vois à l'écrire le ce toutes les fois
où j'ai pas les enfants car genre les
enfants je veux être là je passais plus
tard avec les enfants mais me veil
parfaite jampy je sais pas quelle idée
de fou c'est pas ça qui se passe j'ai
repoussé à plus tard je vais le faire
mais [ __ ] mais l'idée c'est d'amener
l'artiste est farc
bon c'est cool agence j'aime ça c'est la
liberté totale puis tu peux il faut
justement que tu explores en dehors de
ce qui est attendu toit puis genre mais
là je commence à avoir les salles de
théâtre les musées comme des gens de
stylos ou la liberté est tu peux aller
aussi loin que tu veux mais plus tu vaux
loin dans ta liberté plus est appréciée
mais dès que tu sors du lieu de l'or
était un peu à côté de la gauche dès
cette fête fut jugée comme j'ai
l'impression que c'est comme ça ont
défoncé des portes ouvertes c'est comme
attendu qu'on va faire de quoi de a
défait les conventions oui ok mais
défait les conventions tant que sage nom
de 17h au théâtre originale pour ses
piges et j'admire geyser sans critiquer
bon vous comprenez le feu les
conventions et police attentes
oui exactement même on s'attend à ce que
tu les défendez pas que je me suis dit
ou est ce que ça pourrait le plus
georges vraiment avoir un impact ou tu
peux le plus poussé des murs d exister
en politique c'est tellement qui aussi
c'est une grosse scène fait non
seulement c'est facile
amener quelque chose de neuf qui frappe
l'imaginaire paix qui ouvre l'imaginaire
mais en plus c'est la plus grosse
facture avec des galettes ce qui est
encore temps car dedans à plein dans le
fond mais juste pas comme une carrière
c'est plus une posture face à la victime
moi je veux je veux que j'aimerais
j'arrive vraiment pas tout le temps mais
j'aimerais que mon oeuvre ce que j'amène
dans le monde
ça ça ramollissent le coeur des gens
on est obligé que l'état fasse comme au
pit le genre ça ouvre un peu plus et ça
amène du sang nouveau à la pensée puis
là au lieu d'être toujours les mêmes
problèmes des synagogues de titres à
cause de ça comme fuck juste besoin
c'est comme je pense que ce c'est pas
mal proche d'eux on a besoin les uns des
autres
c'est comme si on a besoin de ce
territoire dans faut que tout le show
que j'ai fait avec mon ami mathieu sage
ou quittant noir complet qui a demandé
dans le milieu du show on dit m ok c'est
un show et sonores olfactives pma mieux
de chaumont dictée kusadasi d'aidé au
chanteur si on dit jean ray pour faisait
des scènes plus ce sont tout à coup on
était comme dans un espèce de moment où
serait une espèce de nonnes bouddhistes
ou wever puis je raconte en la
renversant un petit exercice de
visualisation tout le monde
on reprend de cinq minutes dans le
silence pour réfléchir à ce qu'on ferait
si imaginez vous allez chez le médecin
puis médecin vous dit mais
malheureusement vous avez trop jours à
vivre vous avez une maladie grave avec
le on va prendre cinq minutes dans le
silence pour penser à ce que vous feriez
de ses trois dernières journées avant de
mourir placez le noir total
tu vois pas tant mais devant ta face des
gens qui se connaissent pas sont couchés
les uns à côté des autres à ses proches
c'est le silence total puis au bout
d'une minute genre on commence à
entendre
on entend ça danse et art et puis on
laisse comme sont le show continue puis
à la fin jeudi le show est fini jean py
jeudi à un match du soir mathieu du mois
une des affaires que tu ferais d'un
titre ou d'un air gêné lamoureux 10h et
autres à parachute je dis moi je
penserai une nuit au complet d'or dans
une tente avec mise enfin je passe le
micro au public c'était un show juxt un
effectif puissant nord ils pouvaient pas
avoir plus que 100 personnes laissant
personne dise une chose les 500
personnes c'est tellement plus beau
moment du show genre c'est le monde et
foule émue mon cher chaque fois je
pleurais je me disais à mon âge je vais
arrêter mais j'en achète toute affolée
mais que les gens disaient deux affaires
faisaient pas mal pas mal tout pour être
classé dans l'une ou l'autre de ces deux
catégories le il disait je parlerai à
mon père je prends groupe art avec mes
amis ou d'un genre ma blonde mes enfants
il nommait des gens ou bien nommé des
lieux jean monsieur bord du fleuve
mangerait dans montagne marche en
montagne j'ai régent le village à leur
naissance vérité personne qui dit
leveaux à vendre mes actions mais je
travaillais plus ici pour dire qu'à les
deux seules ou les deux seules affaires
qui compte vraiment c'est les gens qu'on
aime puis le territoire qu'on aime c'est
les deux principales choses qui se font
massacrer par le système dans lequel on
vit gens on ne put an pour s'aimer puis
pour ralentir le rythme c'est qu'on
parle d'érosion de l'empathie c'est
grave
puis on ne put le pion on est déconnecté
notre territoire puisqu'il se fait scrap
est acté mais sans indicatif sur quoi
qu'on devrait baser nos actions oui pied
moi je le sens
surtout depuis justement real l'espèce
d'appel intérieur de la nature le sang
versé sur la place sur sa facture un peu
mieux mais je suppose qu'ils sont à
l'envi des justes renouer un petit peu
avec avec
le québec de 250 ans c'est le québec de
comme des chariots pour tirer des îles à
l'entente mais il faut le clairet qui
tue idéalisé seulement 0,1 milan dans le
passé les femmes avaient pas droit
c'est la personne qui veut vraiment
maintenant rêver de cheval vêtue d'un
jean la nature well as la lenteur où il
ya moyen d'avoir un chalet au milieu de
rien et moi cherchons nous à rivière
taff et bouyer se parle aussi du moment
où ce qu'on fait et les parties de
famille que tu manges de la musique la
maison chez qui est tellement kiev et
iphone c'est si c'est aussi donner ça on
peut dire qu'il ya eu des avancées
vraiment l'identité avec mais il ya eu
des avancées sociologique loti justement
les femmes ses meilleurs exemples
d'autres sauf que sauf que c'est vrai
que sur le plan de la fayette me de
l'amisom si je pense juste à la saint
jean vous la saint-jean le ses plaines à
québec ça a été fondateur pour plein de
jeunes gens dont je me rappelle ma
première saint jean je vois jamais
l'oublier le l'espèce de camaraderie tu
arrives il te connais personne d'être un
peu gêné tout les gagnes tu invites
tough des affaires du peu fraîche et
n'importe qui le couple qui sont entrain
de ce printemps sur le frigo qui vient
de se marier cet été leur mariage qui
sont franchis pour la première fois à
saint jacques
mais lorsque c'est devenu c'est fou la
monnaie en fait quand même a lyon me et
imagine seul symbole de tout ça a été
entouré au lieu de laisser le monde
veillées partout il voulait dans la
ville puis les dépanneurs vente d'alcool
puis que bon spigraph le ses rangs du
non on va concentrer sur les plaines
on va mettre une clôture autour du
propane d'état bière sur la clôture cela
écrit périmètre festif s'est décrite
comme expression le futur monde c'est
bien sûr leur circulé on s'en va vers
les plaines georges petitjean avant une
nuit dans l'année une nuit où la ville
nous appartient on a le droit jean py de
temps de s'asseoir ce coin de la rue
tout le monde ensemble on verra bien on
peut tu une fois dans l'année
si avait pas eu de débordements comme ça
c'est un fait
définition c'est un débordement ouais la
personne s'est qualifié dans le feu
jeudi clairement elle avait un problème
de santé mentale grave
et puis je veux dire ok s'il faut
s'arrêter le fleuve peut-être ou porter
mais je veux dire bonté garde il ya
d'autres mondes qui se tue en ce moment
parce qu'on en a pas de faille que parce
qu'elle est la ville du monde qui se
suicident parce que la vie ces grands du
plach noté josé gomez la saint-jean
c'était le genre d'homme ça le marquis
l'imaginaire de générations le sait plus
haut c'est fini parce que parce qu'on a
un pif de même notre réflexe à faire la
fête notre aptitude à faire la fête si
on la pratique pas devenu quoi tu sais
c'est cool de prendre une bière du jazz
et le sait que c'est correct gens mais
sauf que c'est tout ce qui nous reste
quoi le est ce qu'on est capable de
faire d'autres choses ensemble pour ce
fut le seul à vraiment la technologie
salade et 10 super beau davantage puis
ça le défaut qu'on est tout seul chez
nous avec matraques a vraiment la
technologie c'est le stress et la
pression performance si tu peux pas dire
bon il s'en chargent cela que j'ai du
fun ça se passe pas comme son nom soit
détendu
exact
ça fait avant de te laisser partir
saunière on a une question qui nous
vient
à chaque pas de questions on en eau aux
gens qui me suivent de poser des
questions julie roberge ne pose la
question suivante quel est selon toi le
plus grand problème dans le système
politique actuel qui croquait dans le
système politique
c'est quoi mais maintenant si tu avais à
mettre le doigt sur un bobo ben moi je
suis pas un système où chaque joueur
sait pas un bobo mais c'est un bon point
j'en rêve c'est que
notre politique institutionnalisée
comment elle et comment il nous apparaît
ça nous ressemble comme un labyrinthe de
règles de façon de faire conscient qu'il
faut qu'on soit expert à maîtriser ce
avant d'avoir le droit d'accéder donc
plein de monde avec foule de valeur ou
le coeur faux l'intelligence fonds -
janet gérer là parce que c'est un dédale
de règles plus connectés de pas tendre
qui nous façon de faire qui nous donne
l'impression qu'il faut pas que c'est
juste ceux qui ont la motivation de
devenir bon dans cette manière de
fonctionner le de répondre aux médias on
attendait l'inpi qui vont y aller
sigean le cpo nécessairement les
meilleurs personne c'est ça fait un
écrémage désolant l'ofac et comment on
brise ce labyrinthe que des règles en y
allant puis en respectant les limites
comme tu le fais bien et j'essaie autre
qui était de décider de le faire de
l'intérieur tu faisais de l'extérieur
mais le la porte hectos à l'intérieur et
quand même nom et non au oui ça fait ça
fait j'espère que j'ai ce moment je fais
vraiment le voeu que si on force
patients qui souffrent quand même
correction qu'on se force à élargir
l'espace que du monde vont arriver pour
être avec nous parce que on a vraiment
besoin on pourra pour réussir ce qu'ils
font avec toi que je sais qu'il faut
conclure mais c'est qu'elle tisse la
campagne électorale c'est un gros bond
platement de faire de l'à peu puis le la
face les panneaux qui se tourner partout
puis on veut se faire élire pis j'ai
l'impression qu'on sait qu'une fois
qu'on est élu ce come back
je suis élu sait faire c'est réglé ouais
mais occupe toi
justement le fait que tu te forces à cri
un discours qui kiffent brand qui vont
faire vivre une émotion chez le monde
quantique ça se partage petit on dirait
que c'est comme si pour la campagne
n'est pas fini mais le travail continue
tc pau comme c'est réglé c'est bête chu
rendu puis seppi dans quatre ans on se
force sinon moi je suis pas allé là pour
ma foi aurait sinon je serais pas là je
serai dans mon choix dans le beau livre
allait très bien et c'est vraiment sich
voleuse pour faire de quoi la vie moi
j'ai une question pour terminer
est ce que le tout 5 à l'assemblée
nationale il y eut au dessus une
conversation il est ce que les gens
s'écoute est-ce que vous travaillez
ensemble ou travailler contre mais j'ai
juste fait deux semaines mais ce que mon
pays mon intuition c'est que ça n'est
pas vraiment déjanté puis gabriel qui
est qui qui lui 20 mètres bien cacher
les règles petit super bons vivants
malades comme l'a été en tout cas on est
complémentaires mais manon aussi alors
compris toutes les affaires c'est quoi
ce genre
deux autres qui me disent c'est qu'il ya
des choses qu'on peut vraiment aux yeux
du monde sont vraiment par là de parler
de sébastien proulx qui était enseigné
discussions puisqu'elle lui c'est
possible en dehors de la chambre la
chambre ça reste un spectacle on est
quand même la chance et comme un tel
problème de thatta où il vient existe
mais il existe aussi d'autres mondes qui
sont comme un petit peu plus d eau est
parfait et je t'en remercie vraiment
beaucoup mais c'était faux le goût mais
avec le temps
[Musique]